all right I believe if I'm not mistaken
that I am live on YouTube right now this
is my second live stream in a week I
think it's the first time that I've ever
done that to live streams one week that
sounds like a naughty video somewhere
else on the Internet
but yeah I'm doing it because we did the
the pre-election thing a couple days ago
I was in Stockholm Sweden when we did
that right now I am in Birmingham UK or
booming them as they call it here
apparently and I've got the show with
Jordan Peterson in a couple hours as you
can see I'm in my hotel room they're
doing a lot of construction in the back
hopefully the internet connection will
be ok I just wanted to talk a little bit
about what happened in the election and
you know I have to tell you it's a
little weird being I was in Denmark
yesterday when the election was
happening and it's really weird being in
other countries for the last couple days
and I've been in different countries
almost every day from Ireland and
Finland and Norway and Sweden and the UK
and I'm sure I'm forgetting and Holland
and some others I'm sure too and we're
going back to Sweden and we're going
back to Norway and then we're finishing
up in Finland in a couple days then
we'll be in LA and we've got a couple
more shows in Canada in December and
then it looks like we just signed on I
think four six or eight shows in
Australia and February so I'm psyched
about that and then Jordan wants to
continue this into March and April so I
got to see how much I can do and maybe
I'll do some more Rubin reports from the
road and as I said I kind of miss doing
the direct messages for you guys so I
want to figure out how I can be doing
those a little bit more on the road but
you got to strike while the iron's hot
and I'm feeling so good about everything
that's going on and there's just so many
great people that I'm meeting and
realizing that talking about all of
these things transcend borders and the
concerns of people in Norway are the
same as the concerns and the people in
the United States and Brazil and all
over the place it's just it's just crazy
just a couple other things before I jump
in on the election so I get back on
November 12th fly it back from Finland
and then on the 13th I'm doing stand-up
in Brea California and then on the 14th
I'm doing stand-up in Oxnard
fornia both shows will have a surprise
guest from the intellectual dark web I'm
hearing a rumor that for one of the
shows there might be two IDW members
showing up so I do about an hour a
stand-up I bring on the guests for about
45 minutes I did this with Peterson in
Salt Lake City I've done it with Eric
Weinstein I've done it with Christina
Hoff Sommers I've done it with Brett
Weinstein and it's the end up I promise
you like you haven't seen before I do
more of like a town hall situation and
get you guys involved and it's not
politically correct and it's and it's
messy and all over the place but I
promise you you have fun so if you're in
the LA area Brea or Oxnard the links are
down below hope you'll join us we do a
meet-and-greet after 2:00 if you want to
say hi shake my hand touch the hair oh
speaking of the air
I left my toiletry bag in Sweden so for
the last couple days I have not had any
of my stuff I had to buy you know
hairspray and toothbrush and deodorant
and all that but you know I've got my
fancy schmancy hairspray that I normally
use this Oribe dry texturizing stuff
people are always asking me how do I get
the lift in there but now I'm using this
other stuff and it's crinkly and I'm
just not happy about it but thank you
good people for bearing with me okay
cool so so let's talk about the election
a little bit look what did I say a
couple days ago in Sweden day before the
election I said that what I thought
would be best for the country going
forward would be if the Democrats really
got hammered if the idea is that I'm
always talking about on this show that I
really care about that you who watch
this show I think obviously care about
that I sense that young people care
about these days and that I also see as
sort of a wide new coalition of people
who care more about freedom than
Authority if those ideas are the ideas
that matter to you my hope was that the
Democrats who have embraced a real
authoritarian strain and really identity
politics more than anything else judging
each other on your immutable
characteristics instead of your thoughts
and I literally just five or ten minutes
ago before I started this livestream I
just screen captured something from the
women's March where they're tweeting
about white women because not enough
white women voted for Beto to seventy
percent of white women voted for Ted
Cruz in there there's and we've got a
lot of work to do with you white women
like this is becoming the new racism and
it's becoming institutionalized in our
political system and in our media this
is what I would call systemic it's
becoming systemic because they're going
to be passing laws about these things
this is they're gonna be judging people
based on the color of their skin and not
their immutable characteristics and you
should not you should care about what
people think not how they look so all
the headlines today were women win we
had our first Muslim congressman first
openly gay governor of Colorado a couple
other things and it's like okay that
that's all fine no one care you
shouldn't care one way or another it's
nice I suppose but it doesn't matter
what those conditions are what matters
is what are they what do they think what
are their policies are so I because I
believe that identity politics still is
the biggest threat to the west and by
the way if you think I'm exaggerating
this or if you're on the fence about
this or whatever one of the common
themes when I go to all these different
countries with Jordan is that people are
really worried about it all over the
place and they were worried about it in
the Scandinavian countries they're
really worried about it and what's
interesting about that is the
Scandinavian countries you know they're
predominantly white they now are all
dealing with different immigration
situations but even they are being
affected by this so they're not even
that multicultural as a society they
aren't the melting pot that the United
States is but even they are dealing with
these issues and it's all couched within
the political correctness stuff and
people being afraid to say what they
think and all of those things and then
companies you know using this this
diversity myth and all of these things
that actually are as I said
institutionalizing racism where Harvard
won't have Asian applicants and where
companies will say we're gonna have half
women and we're like is it that you're
gonna have the exact proportion of gay
people and women and black people and
Muslims and Jews and all of these things
and ducted up that uh and then you think
what that your product will be better do
you think your society will be fairer or
or more just or good it will be worse it
not only will your product be worse
because you won't be hiring people based
on skills you'll be hiring them based on
those immutable characteristics
but you won't be providing more of a
more of a tolerant society you'll be
creating an intolerant society where
people will look at each other neighbor
will look at neighbor and and be jealous
or angry or expect something of someone
else so it's so it's super dangerous so
anyway what I said before the election
was that what I think the best thing is
for the things that I care about and for
a return to liberalism a left that was
liberal that had a live and let live
attitude but believed there was the
right way to use the government to to
create a grand Society let's say that
has nothing to do with the left anymore
so my feeling was these guys have to be
destroyed I don't want to hurt people
I want the ideas to be rejected so the
better ideas could come so as I laid it
out the other day what I would say is if
if if this leftist monster had been
destroyed out of the ashes of that and
this is a little bit of sort of like a
Jordan Peterson style religious
resurrection out of the ashes of that
perhaps a Phoenix could come forth
perhaps there would be a rebirth of
liberalism now unfortunately that's not
what happened now look it's interesting
what happened here because the Democrat
there was definitely not a blue wave so
let's be clear on that you know
everybody was predicting the blue wave
of the blue way of the blue wave and as
I said the other day it's like anyone
that's predicting anything with
certainty nobody had any clue what was
going on and we can all play armchair
quarterback and we can all we can all
pretend the day after we knew exactly
what was going on but that's pretty rare
and and for it between and especially
these days it's hard to garner what's
going on with the polls my hope you take
out the dangerous elements of the
Democratic Party they return to
liberalism and then their return to a
bit of a centrism
would then cause some of the right the
bad elements of the right say the white
nationalist parts of right which by the
way I don't think are systemic or
massive or that influential but they do
exist but then maybe if the left came a
little closer to center it would be a
little bit easier for the right to read
itself of some of its bad elements and
what I also thought was that maybe if
that had happened Trump then would be
feeling really good like he could do
what he wanted for the next two years
and that maybe he then would realize you
don't have to run on
trolling on Twitter all the time and
fighting the media all the time and all
of those things because I do think we're
gonna eventually get to diminishing
returns on that because I don't think a
society can run on that forever I just
don't think it's possible and that maybe
then Trump would actually moderate some
of the language and I think most people
although it's hard to get say the
hashtag resistance people to admit this
but I think most people realize the
policies of Trump even if you're a lefty
haven't been that bad the rhetoric and
what you may think of him as a person
and all that that's a different story
so that was that was my hope now what
happened okay so the Democrats got the
house back West I heard I think it's
around they got at least 26 seats back
but they're still waiting to find out
more Republicans picked up a couple in
in the Senate so look number one the
real risk of this whole thing would have
been that there had been a blue wave to
the point where the Republican or the
Democrats would have taken the house and
taken the Senate and then we would have
had impeachment of truck there is just
no doubt and what that would have led to
I really believe in this and I didn't
want to say this over the last couple of
weeks because I don't like teasing out
ideas so that they gain momentum scary
ideas let's say is that we would have
ended up in sort of a low-grade cold
Civil War in America if that would have
happened now fortunately because the
Republicans at least kept the Senate and
I say this as someone that has never
even really voted Republican which I
think is worth mentioning over and over
because it seems like I'm defending the
Republicans or that I am a Republican
and I'm not otherwise generally think
their ideas are better at the moment but
had they lost both the House and the
Senate we'd be in a really dangerous
place today I think we would actually
have some serious serious problems on
our hands that did not happen the fact
that the Republicans kept the Senate
basically we won't have impeachment they
the Democrats may try to bring you know
some other investigations on Trump and
that sort of thing look so the danger
right now is this if you're with me on
this identity politics stuff if you're
with me that the left is no longer
liberal and on all of these ideas
there's no reason to think they're not
going to double down again on those
ideas they double down when they
last time to trump and now they've
gained some seats so I think there's no
reason that they wouldn't double down
and say see there's a winning there's a
winning path if we keep up with this and
that's what I think the problem is right
now and as I said the other day what I
think that will lead to is more and more
decent liberals going okay you know what
I can't have a conversation with these
people because every time I open my
mouth they tell me I'm a bigot a racist
and the rest of it just look what the
women's March just tweeted before I
started this live stream and what I will
do is be willing to talk to libertarians
and conservatives and Magga people and
never Trump people because at least
they're a little willing to talk about
these things so I still think there will
be a wide tent developing there I also
think it's possible that if the house
goes so bananas on some of the anti
Trump stuff that that then helps Trump
get reelected because it fires up the
base I did see an interesting tweet
where somebody laid out how many House
seats the incumbent president's party
lost during midterms and for Obama
it was extremely high Clinton high
George HW and W hi Clinton high but for
for trumpet was actually the lowest
since something like nineteen forty six
so that that's just an interesting piece
of information relative to all of this I
suppose I saw some people saying that
that could potentially have something to
do with gerrymandering I would need to
do a little bit more research on that
but in any event I think basically right
now we're pretty much in the same place
we were a couple days ago where there
was no evidence really that the left was
gonna stop going off the deep end now
they're emboldened a little bit and
we'll see what the response is on the
other side I think Trump may be even
speaking right now or he was going to
speak in the next hour or so to address
you know his thoughts after the election
but I just wanted I'll take some
questions by the way so it's
patreon.com/scishow of the record and
I'll take some questions that if you
want to jump in on super chat I will
I'll take some on there as well I've got
a trusty Google Doc here and my guy has
her back in Ellis gins so I will jump in
on that in just a second but you know
one of the other things
that I was thinking as I was looking at
Twitter and trying to track some of the
news and again it's weird being in other
countries when this is all happening
right like I live and breathe this thing
and it was weird like laying in bed last
night at like 2:00 in the morning
watching Danish television talk about
American elections so then finally I
couldn't take it anymore so I switched
to I watch Scarface and then I watched
The Big Lebowski both far more
entertaining the Danish coverage of the
American elections but but every country
that we've been in Finland Sweden
Holland here in the UK obviously the
obsession with American politics doesn't
strike me as good and healthy for for
these countries nor America itself I
mean we really still are the engine and
I think we should be really we should be
careful and we should be responsible
about what that what that means for the
world if we're the engine of how ideas
get put out there if our culture and our
movies and our music and our our
political discourse and everything is
where it all starts and that is that is
where it seems to be then I think we do
have to be careful and it's like look we
had an election yesterday and everyone
said they hate each other and today
everyone's you know some people are
dancing on other people's graves and
other people are upset and this and that
we're not killing each other on the
streets do not forget that do not forget
that that is the important thing here
democracy is still working it is
imperfect it is messy you should fight
for the things you believe in but it's
still working so so we'll see what
happens I also just want to say one
other thing quickly before I get to a
couple questions which is that you know
it seems that politics just always
brings out the worst in us and it seems
that it usually brings out the worst in
us and Twitter and I'm really really
really really gonna commit to being
better than it and it sometimes gets me
like sometimes someone says saying so
stupid I gotta own them or someone says
saying so dishonest or someone goes
after me or whatever it is and I usually
ignore most of it or I try not to add to
it or even when I do something I try to
do it with a little bit a little bit of
sarcasm or snark instead of just like
straight-up vitriol I mean I really
never
do that I don't think not to say I have
never I'm sure I have but I'm really
gonna try not to add to the to the fire
because I think we need some more
firefighters these days and I'm gonna
really try and I hope you'll try and and
we'll see it because I do think we can
win more people by just being a little
bit better I really do so I'm gonna keep
trying that all right let me get to a
couple questions so first we're gonna
jump on patreon questions so it's
patreon.com slash rubin report and and
then we'll take some super chat
questions as well if you want to get
heard you can jump in on there so feel
free to do that reminder just real quick
I am back in LA on November 12th and
then on the 13th I'm doing stand-up at
the Brea improv and then I'm at levity
live in Oxnard California both are
outside of LA and I will have an ID W
guest with me on both days oh and by the
way if you sign up on patreon Reuben
select level 3 or higher you get a free
you get free entrance into my
meet-and-greet and I hang out with
people after it's show Oh real quick and
then I promise I'll get to the questions
so we knew these meet and greets after
the show and Jordan does these these
really extended meet and greets and it's
usually about 100 people mine have 20 30
40 or so usually sometimes a little bit
less it depends and the Sweden one we
had like 50 people and it was so cool we
had this huge huge table with standing
room only and I kind of held court and
it was just great it was just so much
fun like I really feel like being on
this tour it's it's changed me in that
like I really am meeting and connecting
with so many great people all over the
world and people are coming up to us all
over the place and sometimes Jordan goes
out into the into the audience into the
line outside the theatre before we start
and and we're messing around with the
crowds and we're just having a blast so
I hope you guys will come to the shows
if you haven't if you haven't yet and it
looks like we're gonna be doing Germany
and Belgium and and Turkey and Israel
and all over the place I mean it seems
like we're just gonna keep going and
going so we shall see what happens okay
I live in rural America how can i
balance my libertarian philosophy with
the fact that the population in my area
can't support the kinds of school and
infrastructure investments that will
provide
the equality of opportunity that is so
important to me in my offering what a
great question because what you're
saying basically is your libertarian so
you want local local local but you know
in a rural area like that there may not
be enough money to actually fund the
types of things that you want so this is
this is a really good one this is a
place where I would say you you and your
local representatives should be fighting
as much as possible that depending on
what state you live in to get your your
local area more resources or you move
right so that's that's the easy answer
as you move if they're if the resources
aren't right for your area and your
libertarian you move someone else you
use your foot vote okay but putting that
one aside you know I'm from New York so
New York has an interesting part of this
because there's a constant battle
between the mayor of New York City and
where there are some odd you know I
think it's around 8 million people and
then the governor of New York who's up
in Albany upstate who has to deal with
the entire state where there's huge
rural areas and there's farms and huge
distances between people there's the the
southern tier area I went to SUNY
Binghamton so southern tier area which
is part of upstate New York is really
really economically depressed right now
so there's a constant battle between the
governor who has to take care of the
entire state and the mayor of New York
City who has the most people there so he
argues that he needs the most resources
and how do you allocate all of that and
it's like there's such a concentration
of people there you could see a governor
going rest of us they in votes right
down there so the best thing you can do
is hopefully you have a decent local
representative a decent state senator
let's say and you can get them to lobby
for more resources in your area I would
say there's you know there's probably
other ways maybe through homeschooling a
little bit or online learning things
like that but if it's really bad like if
you live in an area that's really being
ignored and you've tried to fix it you
know sometimes you just gotta go and
again this is this is shitty right this
is the argument that I make about why I
wouldn't force the Baker to make the the
cake for the gay wedding it's like I
don't want the government coming in and
telling
a private company what to do what
service to offer and if you happen to
live in a town where the only Baker
won't make you the cake the specific
cake for your wedding well then you you
can either get a cake online and that
works right that does work and it
doesn't feel great probably but it does
work or you can move so you know it's a
really great question because it sort of
puts your beliefs to the test and that's
kind of what it's all about and you
should try to live in a place where the
ideas and the ideals that you care about
are rewarded and are then feel like they
matter so that's it's a really great
question and I don't know that there's
really like a perfectly right answer to
that it's sort of also what do you need
like if you really value say the land
you live on and the freedom that that
affords you and things like that maybe
then that overrides some of the other
issues that you're talking about it's
interesting let's say super chat I asked
Tim Poole this yesterday do you think
it's smart for the Dems
to portrayed Trump as the worst
international as the worst to the
international community as Americans
hello from Australia by the way oh well
first off as I just said I think I just
said it we're going to Australia I think
six or eight stops in February so I'll
let you know about that it's somewhere
between like February 6th and 18th we're
trying to figure it all out so hope
you'll come to one of the shows do I
think it's a good move for them to play
it off that internationally Trump is the
worst not really because internationally
right now look Trump has done pretty
good work with nikki Haley at the UN to
really just completely decimate a
seriously corrupt organization that
makes the Legion of Doom look look like
you know Barney's Playhouse design does
Bonnie have a playhouse something like
that so internationally I do sensed that
some of our allies actually trust us a
little bit more right now you know I
think the the Obama Red Lion in Syria
thing was one of the worst foreign
policy mistakes
probably in 50 years because our allies
suddenly trusted us less because he said
if you if you use chemical weapons
that's our redline and then they did and
we didn't do anything not that I wanted
to do anything you can go
you know five years ago and watch when
the Syria war was really heating up you
can watch videos of me on The Young
Turks talking about how I did not want
the United States to be involved at all
that sometimes other countries
surrounding countries like Saudi Arabia
and Turkey should get involved and at
and perhaps the United States could
offer a little bit of a humanitarian
corridor for people to to go to but that
would be it so I don't know that
painting him more scarily let's say to
the international community would work
look he's talking to North Korea right
now
you know we've redone some of these
trade deals yeah there's still like the
personality element that's still a
little bizarre maybe you can play that
up I'm not I just don't know that it's a
winnable strategy though let's see all
right I'll jump in one more one more
superjet opinion of florida giving
felons the right to vote yeah so I just
heard about this one so I guess there
was a referendum on this and felons who
could not vote now will be able to vote
look if you've done your time you are
still a citizen of the United States of
America so I don't really see a
counter-argument to that I suppose if
you did something that was directly
related to election fraud perhaps or
something like that but let's say you're
a felon you're an armed robber you armed
you robbed a bank
you know you serve your time you serve
ten years you're now thirty eight you
get out of jail and you're trying to
rebuild your life should you never be
allowed to take part in the election
process again I don't see how that is
fair so basically I would need to know a
little bit more about the specifics of
this but basically I think it's actually
totally fine
let's see Dave why don't you do an alt
technique like a youtuber week interview
the guys behind shoot dab mind
cetera so I've been thinking about doing
something like this because it's
obviously so much of what's going on
here now politically culturally
technologically is directly related to
the ways that we can communicate right
I'm sitting on my laptop computer which
is on top of the small garbage can by
the way in in Birmingham UK and you guys
are watching this all over the world
that's
cool but if the company is in this case
Google that that owned the pipes and on
the wires and on the Wi-Fi and on the
airwaves and all of that stuff if they
want to slowly clamp down on certain
types of speech which I think there is
evidence that they would like to do some
of that at least a little bit then we
should be talking about alternative
technologies here as you guys know from
my talks with Peter teal in my talks
with Eric Weinstein and a couple others
there's plenty of discussion in this in
this arena I can't give you all the
discussion about that that I'm privy to
at the moment but I do think that's a
good idea you actually get some of the
cool tech people in here to discuss some
of these things maybe I can smoke a
blunt with a lawn Musk all right let's
see okay oh and a reminder I've already
picked it out twice but the links to the
Brea show on the 13 and the Oxnard Show
on the 14th are right down below so I
hope you guys will join me for some
stand-up and meet some of the IDW crew
all right
shouldn't we stick around and fight to
reform and push back on the left also
because of what you're seeing out there
how do you feel about the possibility of
a third party that might just be able to
rise
look the stay and push back thing I
think there are great arguments on both
sides so Eric Weinstein who has become
like a brother to me who is one of the
greatest minds I think on earth he still
considers himself part of the left and
he believes that it can be reformed from
the inside I see no evidence of it and
not only do I see no evidence of it I
see a continued slow slide to all the
things that I don't like and I see more
and more people get purged for any sort
of free thought I see them using the
ideas of collectivism which is a type of
racism actually and is a type of sexism
and is a type of bigotry I see them
using those ideas more and more and more
again go check with women's March tweet
that I just sent out right before this
stream white women you know we're coming
for you white women if you don't do what
we want you to do we're for women or for
women know that but you better do what
we want you to do otherwise we're not
for you which is why saying you're
for women over your for gay people or
for black people is actually stupid it's
it's not a clear thought-out logical
argument because if you're four it
doesn't make sense women think different
things but people think different things
gay people think different things so
what can you be for oh my god the broken
record of you can be for the individual
that's what you could be for so as for
staying look let's say let's say Eric's
right and I'm wrong and a couple bandits
inside the left can can blow up the the
machine and fix it and everything else
and suddenly JFK liberals are all over
the place and you know they believe in
somewhat of a slimmer trimmer government
but they don't think government's the
answer to everything they don't believe
in identity politics etc etc that would
be freaking spectacular and I will
gladly say man good you guys did it
fantastic what I can see is it wouldn't
be honest of me to say that I am part of
that anymore
I'm just not and not only am I not but
but me and all of my crew that you guys
all know none of us get invited to
anything on the left by college campuses
or organizations or anything we get
invited by conservatives and we look
Eric Weinstein and I spoke at the Iran
instance good Iran is a basically a
libertarian organization there's a
little there's obviously more to
objectivism than just that but they're
they're pretty far on the right
especially on economics and an eric went
up there and said all sorts of things
against libertarianism against
objectivism against ein Rand and her
writing and all sorts of stuff I've got
a huge ovation after and then we had a
cocktail hour and everybody was having a
great time
I mean you simply never see that on the
other side so and this is also where you
know we all get invited on Fox News and
I go on because they don't edit me and I
go on Tucker live and I go on Greg
Gutfeld live and we don't get invited to
CNN or MSNBC so that it just is what it
is so I will find allies where allies
are and if I keep putting my hand out to
one side and they keep biting me and I
keep putting out my hand out to another
side and where I see that they are they
are malleable that there that the Young
Conservatives look at Kyle cashew who I
had on a show last week a brilliant
young kid and they don't care about gay
marriage anymore they they don't really
care about
I think there even though most of them I
think are pro-life they're willing to
have a discussion about about abortion
they're willing to have a discussion
about dignity with death and things of
that nature so I will go and talk to
those people because they're willing to
talk to me and I'm also I'm also
confident in what I believe in and what
my knowledge is and I believe if I sit
down with people you know there's this
idea I think people on the left are so
afraid that if you sit down with someone
they're gonna trick you and you're gonna
become one of them but I'm as confident
in my ideas as they probably are in
theirs and I believe we can have that
out and I'm not afraid of that so I
think you can make a good argument as
for the third party thing look this is
the this is the really really tough part
if you're a libertarian these days if
you're a libertarian I could see why
you'd say you know what forget the
Republicans they keep putting everything
else aside for getting Trump all that
they always spend more right they talk
about smaller government but they always
spend more even when they cut taxes
they're still spending more including
Trump so I can see why you'd want to be
a third party and I thought Larry sharp
did a really nice job in New York and he
busted his ass and you know what he
didn't even get two percent it's very
unfortunate he was on my show he was on
Rogen's show he didn't get any
mainstream coverage really but he really
really did try and he's a good guy and I
hope he has a bright future in front of
him and I'm sure we'll cross paths again
now the inherent problem with this is
okay so if the Libertarian Party really
imagine if they really pull it together
they get some great you know dynamic
young person and people to run down
ticket to because part of their problem
is they do very little down ticket and
then they throw someone for you know for
presidency and then it just looks stupid
that the problem is that all right so
let's say they do the most amazing
Returns ever for a living for turns
let's say they get 10% 12% well what do
you I mean you've taken at least 8 9
percent of that from Republicans and you
guarantee the Democrats win and then and
then that's not good now I discuss this
with Larry sharp and what he would say
is you've got to do that because
otherwise you'll just never change and I
think that's an interesting argument
right
like you've gotta go we're gonna get 10%
this time but lose knowing that
hopefully next time we'll have a little
momentum and maybe we can get it
eighteen percent then maybe after that
we can get it to 20 percent and then
maybe we get to a tipping point and we
go from 24 percent to 41 percent or
something like that I think that's a
totally legit argument can we survive
you know you know 10 12 14 years of what
that do with this new left in charge I
don't know but I would to say at the
same point the left is the epicness
themselves it's like the old-school
liberals who are at this point and and
the progressives have very little in
common so what is your party which is it
going to be run by and perhaps they need
to split let the progressives have
before our last stuff let them happen it
and maybe that is where the momentum is
for them but all right let them have it
and then and have sort of the more
old-school liberal party let Joe Biden
run a party for his last you know be
grandpa the old the girls or whatever I
don't know I don't know and then they'd
have to deal with same reckoning right
that I just mentioned because then they
would ensure basically that a Republican
Party comes back so I guess the best
answer is that the both parties would do
it at the exact same time pretty rare
it's a tough question and it's one of
those things it's like it's it's just a
matter of how much risk are you willing
to take I think in your decision-making
okay a any plans on coming to the
capital of decentralized power
Switzerland I don't know why Switzerland
was it on the list here I will ask
Jordan tonight and I will find out hang
tight on that one let's see
have you considered interviewing
conservatives who are more skeptical of
free-market economics i Roger Scruton or
Peter Hitchens I'd love to interview
scrutiny Jordan had lunch with or dinner
with him a couple days ago and I was
invited but I ended up going back to
London to do something but we're
connected now so hang tight I hope I can
work that one out and Peter Hitchens and
I we've traded a couple emails I really
wanted to do it in studio like you know
what maybe I can do it next time I'm I'm
in London I think he lives in London
actually I have a day off in London
tomorrow I'm doing something really cool
actually if you guys remember my my
interview with Katherine verbal sing
which was in August she is she's an
educator who created her own charter
school the Michaela school here in
London and they're doing just
great work helping kids get out of
poverty helping families really showing
what personal responsibility is all
about their kids are getting great
grades they're actually teaching and
it's and it sounds like it's just a
wonderful school and I was totally
inspired by her so I'm gonna go take a
tour of the school tomorrow with her and
then I'm gonna speak to some of the kids
in the afternoon which is pretty cool
but maybe I can reach out to Peter and
see if I can at least maybe I can just
meet him for coffee or tea as they have
here and you know London and then we'll
see let's see hey Dave do you think the
phoenix rising from the ashes scenario
will actually need to happen through a
complete leftist take over as ran
projects as ran projects and out of
shrug
do you think leftists will have to see
the toxicity of their policies play out
before they're willing to abandon them
yeah you know it's like and that's why I
said I started at the beginning of this
thing I think by the Democrats getting
the house here what we're gonna get is
sort of just this slow descent into more
of this nonsense
where I would say at this point the most
healthy thing would have been a
destruction a weird couple years where
they would have had to reconstitute the
party and have a read have the real
fight like we're not doing anything real
right now we're not having the real
fights we should be we should be willing
to have real political fights not just
sort of political bickering over over
winning points so I think yes like well
again this is why this tweet that the
women's March just sent down white women
watch out white women we're looking at
you if you don't do what we want you to
do it's why it's so dangerous and so
actually racist and and and it's
inherently anti freedom so I think that
enough of them will have to start seeing
that like if the next move what the left
does is it eats a group and then eats a
group and then eats a group and then
eats a group and then eats a group well
if the next move now is they've sort of
white men they've been going after white
men for a long time if the next move is
alright we're gonna go after white women
maybe some white women will start waking
up and go wait a minute wait a minute I
don't I don't have to vote if I'm
pro-life let's say and I'm conservative
on this or that or and I want lower
taxes and states rights
whatever it is I don't have to be part
of the women's March I don't have to and
I won't be guilted into it and then when
you corner them they start coming out
stronger so I think that that's that's
possible I mean think about the women's
March so that means there are four women
well are they for nikki Haley who I
think is you know I'd probably vote for
president and who I think is one of the
strongest your Republican governor of
South Carolina goes into the UN and is
the US rep there and just cracked skulls
and who has just been a spectacular
fighter for American values and who
comes from an immigrant family and all
of these things that America is all
about are they for her they're not so
don't tell me you're for women you're
for women who behave as you wish them to
behave um let's see how much do you
think late night quote comedy shows like
Stephen Colbert John Oliver some have to
be effect election results I would say
very little very little I can't imagine
you know I think they're mostly
preaching to the choir one of the things
that I'm so proud of is that I still to
this day and I'm always for the last
couple years I get emails from people of
every political persuasion in every
country gay straight black blah blah
blah
doesn't matter but that are all over the
place some that are that are now waking
up to what they see with you know I'm
left I've been a lefty my whole life I'm
now waking up to this and then I get
emails from Christian conservatives and
I get emails from libertarians and all
of these different people who are all at
different stages of this and I think
part of the reason for that is that
we're having honest conversation here I
am NOT I'm telling you what I think for
better or worse you're you're sharing
your questions with me your comments
we're doing this in long-form you can
hear something that I'm doing and then
take an idea and then perhaps Sam Harris
is gonna talk about it in a different
way or in a way that I disagree with on
his podcast you're gonna see Eric
Weinstein and I disagree on things
you're gonna watch Joe Rogan and I talk
about different things and you're gonna
be able to formulate your thoughts those
shows are not really places of
formulating thought they're all sort of
that that a Trump that that a Trump like
it's not that interesting
funny or amusing so I don't think people
really I think a certain amount of
people may be guilted into voting a
little bit by them but I don't think
people really pay attention to it which
is which is nice Dave when will a I
become an election issue man what a
great question um I would say that by
twenty let's say by 2024 it'll be the
big one I don't think it'll I don't
think by in two years in 2020 it'll be a
big issue it'll it'll have move forward
a little bit for sure and with more
automation comes more issues about the
economy and minimum wage and all sorts
of things and you bi and whatever else
but I don't think it'll be huge in two
years I would say the election the
presidential election after that so say
2024 I think that will be possible how
do I get you to come to my school so I'm
going all over the place and when I'm
when I'm not with JP I'm traveling and
doing schools by myself you can go to
Dave Rubin comm slash contact and put in
the request I send it over to my agents
and then as long as we can work it out
works with my schedule and everything
else we're good to go
um let's see Dave take a break and play
some pug G with me I don't know what
that is I'm getting old are you excited
for Super Smash Brothers ultimate or is
that not your thing
I played Smash Brothers a bunch and you
know as I always tell you guys I don't
really have time for video games anymore
I can play like little bites here and
there I've been playing a little NBA
live with my brother and my nephew but I
don't have really time but so a game
like Smash Brothers I can play quick
because I can play it with a couple
friends right there and we can do it and
it's totally fun people keep asking for
my playstation name so that we can
connect on there maybe maybe one day
when I like take a Wii or you know
August when I go off the grid maybe I
would take like two days and make them
like video game days and I'll I'll play
with you guys all over the place that
actually could be kind of fun oh I do
want to give you a little a little
career tip a nutnut tip I want to give
you a little career hint as to something
good that's happened but I'll wait
towards the end to do that but a lot of
good things are happening all right
let's see I've been saying for a long
time that if Trump would dial back the
rhetoric from an eleven to an eight and
reduce the personal ad
attacks he would attract another 10 to
20 percent of the electorate from the
middle that dismisses him because of the
behavior your thoughts yeah I basically
agree with you now I think he's sort of
at some level he sort of needed to do it
when he was running the first time he
had to break through the political
correctness he had to break through the
mainstream media he had to garner the
attention all of those things now that
he's present especially because things
are going basically okay the economy is
chugging along we're not going into
extra Wars were redoing some of the
trade deals things of that nature okay
the things were basically gone okay you
know net neutrality no one's been killed
Paris of course we're not dying etc etc
it would be interesting and this is why
I was saying if the Republicans would
have won that might have given him
enough breathing room to start doing
that dial back some of the rhetoric you
don't have to just be the trolling chief
so hopefully I think there's still a way
for him to do that because if the
Democrats now go you know feel really
emboldened and they think all right well
now we can we can attack Trump we can
still try for impeachment even though it
would be an impossibility whatever else
it is
and then Trump imagine if he steps back
sorry about that light over there
imagine if he steps back and it's like
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna be the
more mature party here I can't believe
it
nobody else could believe it but I'm
gonna try it that would I think help him
that he's got the people that want the
trolling the people that want to own the
Lib tards and all that stuff he's got
pretty much not gonna lose them because
those people aren't gonna go to the left
so you got those guys so there's a way
to get the other people that are
concerned legitimately I think about
sort of a trolling and some of the
rhetoric and that kind of stuff I know
plenty of those people because I think
there's an actually I think you know the
10 to 20 percent you mentioned here I
think I think that's a pretty fair
number because I know plenty of people
right now lefties liberals let's say who
when I talk to privately they're like
you know I don't think things are that
bad right now I think things were kind
of alright actually and I have a little
more money in my paycheck and my IRA or
401k is doing a rioter blah blah blah
investments are doing all right
but I don't like the rhetoric and they
can't get over that so why keep giving
it to them I don't and and it would be
nice if we had a little more return to
normalcy in terms of the rhetoric
because again I don't think we can last
on this this sort of crazy tenor forever
I just don't think it's possible all
right do we got fifth tenets reminder
people I'm gonna doing stand-up again I
don't know why but it's been it's been
awesome we've sold out every single show
that we've done and they're great I do
about an hour a stand-up I get you guys
involved we do giveaways and it's fun
it's like no stand-up show you've ever
seen I promise you so I will be in Brea
California on November 13th the link is
right down below and then I'll be in
Oxnard California on the fourteenth link
right down below I've got an ID W
character joining me for both shows and
I'm hearing a rumor that there might be
a second one so I do hope you'll join me
and if you join at patreon.com so that's
Ruben report on level three or higher
you get a free meet-and-greet I will
shake your hand I will take a picture
with you sometimes people hug me which
is always as long as you don't hug for
too long
there's always that moment where the hug
goes from like oh that's nice you're a
stranger you're showing me affection to
like laughs we better ease up on that
but yeah so we can do all that let's see
Democrats fed power in California for
decades and things have gotten worse for
the middle class what hope do you see in
California now that Newsom will be
governor yeah I mean I'm not very
hopeful actually which is ironic because
I love living in Los Angeles and I can
tell you that even in in LA there has
been and he's just becoming governor now
but the amount of homeless people has
increased tremendously well last time I
was in Berkeley our car got broken into
on a pretty nice Street we were at a
steak joint the car got broken into
basically in front of the steak joint
Morton's Steakhouse so like a nice place
and they stole stole my bag my my
sister's parents my sister's parents
in-law were visiting from out of the
country they were in Berkeley just a
couple weeks ago and they got mugged in
broad daylight they literally ripped the
rings off my brother-in-law's mother's
finger
pretty violent I mean she's bruised the
whole thing so I think there's some bad
trends in California for sure I mean in
in San Francisco they've got an app to
tell you where human poop is on the
street I am NOT making that up
I saw somebody shooting up in Berkeley I
got on a side street so there's a lot of
trends that are bad in California good
Newsom
it's got good hair he's got a nice smile
as all the right things but he's for big
government he thinks the government can
resolve all of these things and I don't
think government can I think government
basically makes all of these things
worse so I'm not very hopeful
unfortunately for California because it
which sucks because I love living in
California and you can't beat the
weather and I really do like the people
and in LA there's a resurgence of some
interesting political conversation
happening I mean you know Shapiro's here
in l.a and dennis prager is here in LA
and peter Till's here in LA and sam
Harris is here in LA and plenty of other
people are here in LA right now so there
is an interesting intellectual set
happening in LA and I you know it's just
unfortunate but if somebody want to may
move to Texas make me an offer I can't
refuse
ok let's see-oh pub G is player unknowns
battleground for ps4 I don't know what
it is but I'll check it out but if
someone give me like a contra style game
that I can just blow some stuff up and
hopefully it's a side scroller I would
love to or more like a like a life force
Gradius kind of shooter but I want to go
that way I don't want to go that way
can't go that way don't want to go this
way I want to go that way or I guess I'd
go that way but can't do it the other
way to do all right let's see are there
any future endeavors with Brett Eric
and/or Heather well I don't wanna give
away too much but I just told you that
you know potentially there are some IDW
people joining me for my stand-up gigs
November 13th in Umbria and November
November 14th in Oxnard so you might
want to check out one of those shows you
know comes in and oh and actually
Brett's gonna be on the show in a couple
of days when I get back also so that's
so there you go so yeah so I'm gonna
keep talking to these guys who now you
know we definitely have some
disagreements with then it's all good
it's all good people okay let's see um
here we go we got about 12 minutes left
and then I gotta I gotta get dressed I
gotta meet J Peter he's on his like 8
steak of the day you know the guys only
eatin steak and and basically in club
soda and salt these days so he eats a
tremendous amount of steak I'm still I'm
still doing this paleo thing as much as
I can but I've been eating a lot of
steak because I hang out with the guy a
lot let's see who do you see running in
2020 that has the power to actually
unite the country from where we're
standing today I don't know I don't know
if there is somebody right now that
could do it I don't think there's anyone
in sort of traditional politics that can
do it this isn't the right answer but
I'll get I'll sort of throw this one out
it's just like the idea if there was
somebody that was like a Schwarzenegger
now I don't know it's not gonna be him
enough he wasn't even born in the United
States so it's not a possibility but
somebody that was basically a that had a
you know certain amount of star power a
little bit of political history he was
the Governor of California obviously and
that was basically a moderate Republican
I think that would be the ticket to do
it but it's not Schwarzenegger so I
don't know is there anyone else lining
that like I don't want it to be Clooney
or just like some actor that comes in
and does it I don't think that's the
right thing I don't know that there's
anyone that's a career politician at the
moment it would have to be someone
pretty pretty centrist that I think had
a basic belief in the Constitution
I wanted to rein in government a little
bit and and wasn't really playing
identity politics but but was willing to
give the damn something on the other
side I don't know I don't know who that
is you got any good ideas let me know
okay let's jump back in so we got about
ten more minutes I'll take some more on
on super chat as well if you want to
just jump in there
let's see perhaps it's not just big
government that's the problem perhaps
it's big organizations problem of
imbalance of scale between an
organization its power and the powers of
the individual well look this is this is
why I love talking about the YouTube
situation in the Google situation so
much because it's about it's about
authoritative powers and the government
usually is the ultimate one of those
right but when we have a company like
Google that controls the amount of
information and infrastructure and wires
and pipes and everything that they have
of course they can become a problem as
well I mean I've addressed that many
times the issue is well then do you want
to give more power to the government to
then decapitate some of that power
that's that's a tough question and I've
heard good arguments on both sides I
tend to think the answer is no because
once you give power over to something be
at the government or a private
organization it's very rare that it
gives the power back and there's always
a unique situation so it's like Google
strikes me as a truly truly truly unique
situation but that's probably the same
thing that people said about Microsoft
in 1987 or you know plenty of other
things over the years so this is where
I'm still more interested in letting the
market figure it out but does could
there be some touch from the government
that makes some sense you know I'm
willing to have that conversation and
you know that's a where I recommend sign
we've discussed it on their last live
stream a month or two ago so yeah
there's good people on both sides of
that and I think it's a I think it's a
totally fair question let's see here
I'll jump back into the patreon for a
moment any advice on how I should
introduce my friends to the IDW um you
know I found her one of the things that
people say to me all the time
when I meet people at these shows or
content about the airport or whatever is
that the the Praeger you video why I
left the left is I think it's their
number one video ever actually and they
had some major people on there and it's
pretty awesome that it is and I think it
sort of encapsulates what initially
brought the IDW together even though of
course some of those folks still
consider themselves part of the left as
I talked about earlier I
would say that that video if you can get
that to somebody look it's it's pleasant
it's whatever it is three or four
minutes they don't have to agree with
everything but I think I talked about
the right issues in a con in a competent
and clear way that I think will open
them up to some of these ideas and then
from there then I would say you should
have them watch you know it's like you
want to kind of ease them into some of
this stuff I suppose you know another
good one that well the video that we did
our only animated video that we've ever
done what is a classical liberal you
could show them at and then I think that
also could frame a little bit of these
issues for them and then and then just
sort of get them in on some of these
conversations maybe my first
conversation with Sam Harris because
that's kind of where it all started with
me pick one of the conversations with
Jordan Peterson you know any of the ones
with Eric and then there's the ones that
are straight up less political that say
you could have the malecon listen to the
conversation with Brett Weinstein as he
was in the midst of the Evergreen
situation or the conversation with James
d'amour as he was in the midst of the
Google situation or the conversation
with Lindsey Shepherd as she was in the
midst of the wilfred laurier situation
my conversation a couple weeks with
Coleman Hughes I think is a good fit you
know I think more than anything else
show people that there are some other
folks out there who are willing to talk
who are willing to listen who don't want
to braid and harangue and dismantle
society who are just trying to figure it
out just like they are and it's getting
harder and harder and I suspect it's
gonna just keep getting harder and
harder now you know it's like there's no
doubt right now that the sides are just
gonna keep going so it's like those of
us that want to live with some people
who are different than us that don't
think we have a right to take from some
and give to others and all of that and I
do think that's most of us those of us
who want to live and let live those of
us who don't care what your neighbor
smokes in his house or who your other
neighbor is sleeping with or whatever
else it's like that is most of us that
is the beauty of America everyone has
come here from everywhere for
hundreds of years now and made a better
life for themselves you person watching
this right now I guarantee you you have
a better life if you live in America
than your grandparents did you can say
that with almost 99% certainty and if
you don't it's actually a great argument
against leftism too because they ate
accumulated wealth going out down from
generation to generation so if you
screwed up if your grandparents were
really rich and you're really poor
that's also a great argument for our
evil capitalistic patriarchy because the
accumulated wealth doesn't always stay
right so it's pretty damn good here and
let's not forget that in the name of
trying to go for some utopian society
that's never existed you can try to make
it better but that doesn't mean you have
to destroy the whole damn thing it's a
hell of a lot easier to destroy rather
than create so these people and that's
one of the things it's like these people
who have never done anything all these
think piece writers and these HuffPo
writers and BuzzFeed writers they've
never done anything they've never hired
anyone they've never created anything
and it's like if only they could run the
world everything would be okay no no no
no no let's scale back the power that we
have over each other so that we can all
live as freely as possible and you can
decide how much good you want to do for
your community for yourself or other
people etc etc that you could argue I
suppose it's a little utopian but it's
utopian within the confines of us having
to be free and then we can discuss on
the margins how much should we be taxed
because I do believe we have to be taxed
how much should we have for defense or
how much should we have for this or that
how much wood should we have for
infrastructure can some of this be done
by private enterprise etc etc these are
all the things we can discuss and I
think you guys that are watching or
listening to this do want to discuss
these things and you want to get too
much your answer so I'm gonna keep
interviewing the people that I think
have the right answers or at least are
thinking about the right answers or
willing to have conversations about the
right answers all right let's see
someone said I think Dwayne the rock
Johnson would be great you know a couple
people have tweeted that at me lately I
don't know exactly where his politics
are but could he be the type of person
that comes from the Schwarzenegger mould
almost literally in this case maybe but
like it right does it
all have to be so celebrity driven and
what does that really say
Society I'm not sure oh and someone said
broforce awesome side-scrolling
multiplayer shooter I have it it's
totally fun I've been playing a
four-player especially when you're
you're playing with a couple of friends
it's just like complete chaos and
nuttiness it's almost like a little too
much for me because there's so many
explosions happening at the exact same
time okay let me tell you a little bit
about some career stuff that's that's
cookin so there's a lot of good things
cooking and as I said being on this tour
with with Jordan has it's been like a
truly life-changing I have enjoyed every
second of it I've connected with four
people ice last night in Denmark I saw
Fleming Rose Fleming who I've had on the
show who is the publisher in the Danish
magazine of the Mohammed cartoons I
think that was 2003 he is a spectacular
advocate for free speech and free
expression and just the most decent warm
guy you're ever gonna meet so I had
dinner with him last night I had dinner
with Douglas Murray last week I'm gonna
try to seem odd maybe tomorrow I've
connected with old friends high school
friends I've gone out with fans after
the show I've met all sorts of people
I'm really just having a blast I feel
good and long it you know as long as I
keep basically eating right and trying
to get to the gym every now and again
I've been walking around these cities
it's giving me perspective on the world
you know I never thought I was gonna go
to all of these countries like this and
even though some of them are only for a
day it's like you get a little flavor of
how other people you know you see just
differently or look differently or
whatever it is it's been totally
inspiring and I think it's I think it's
helping me it's helping me sharpen my my
tools to do what I do and hopefully I
can do maybe more international shows
and I think actually if Jordan and I do
end up extending this into March in
April which it sounds like we will I'm
thinking about doing more shows on the
road like really well we'll start rent
and you know cruise and that'll thing uh
but I did get some great news last week
so you guys know or most of you know
that I've been talking about this book
forever so I I haven't I don't want to
give you too much right this moment cuz
there will be an announcement like
thinking about a week or so but my book
has been picked up it is by a primo
primo publisher the whole thing the way
the whole deal has worked out is is
beyond a dream come true I'm working on
it where I don't want to give you
publishing dates and all that yet but
I'm super super psyched it's a this
thing's going to be a freaking labor
love a lot of it also for me was I
wanted to get through this current
election because I wanted to publish it
sometime between the midterms and the
presidential election not that it's
purely about politics but I thought
there'll be an interesting moment for
the country in there so now that we're
past that I can focus in on it a little
bit different but we have closed the
deal with the publisher so I'm really
psyched about that and that's one of the
ancillary benefits I think of doing this
show with this tour with Jordan because
it's like I'm willing to bust my ass to
promote it and do the right thing and
get back out on the road and share these
ideas and I gotta tell you there's one
other thing about Jordan I mean you know
he says it often because it comes up in
the Q&A so when we do about a 40 minute
Q&A at the end of the show and people
will ask you know like do you ever get
tired or you how do you stay inspired
and he's like he's like I'm sharing my
ideas all over the world and millions of
people are buying my books and I come to
speak to thousands of great people like
you like what could be better than this
and you know I get a little of that
extra glow from from his people but I
get it from you guys all the time and
this thing is continually growing and
I'm doing the best I can and I'll make
mistakes along the way but you know I
think I think we're on to something
really great and I sense we're just at
the beginning again which is crazy
because how could that be but maybe
that's sort of what life is you keep
working and working and working in this
somehow don't always know what you're
working for and then there's wow there's
a new beginning and then you go this way
and then there's another new beginning
and you go this way but if you if you do
what you can do with a little with some
rigor and some passion and some honesty
I think good things good things come I
guess that Peterson guy has weren't off
weren't on me all right guys we did
about an hour I gotta uh I gotta get
myself ready for the big show in
Birmingham tonight
we'll be in Oslo tomorrow we are in
Denmark the day after that and then we
are in Finland the day after that and
then I take a crazy stop flight 12 hours
some situation back to LA on the 12th
Brea stand up on the 13th link is right
down below Oxnard on the 14th link is
right down below and then there's some
other stand-up stuff that's listed in
there and all that good stuff anyway
thanks as always and okay I'm gonna
enjoy my hotel room for 15 minutes
before I go meet Jordan all right ciao
guys see ya